Meet an all-American kid.
Quarterback of his middle school football team.
President of the student council and one of the strongest students in his class.
A 12-year-old with a face arching back to those warriors of the Lakota Sioux past...
...like Sitting Bull, Crazy Horse, James Lone Elk.
A boy who has their face and is trying to find their strength.
His name is Robert Looks Twice, his long hair an Indian symbol of honor.
And at the tribal dance, he has mastered the fierce precision to every beat of the drum:...
...the hunter echoing the movements of his prey.
At the dances, Robert wears the highest honor given by the tribal elders:...
...eagle feathers, because they reach toward the sky.
At the competition, he wins prize money...
...which he shares with the grandmother who gave him a home.
It's like, I'm just happy to be with the family that loves me, right now.
And when he gets to the White House, he promises...
...he'll make sure his grandmother Blossom has one of her favorite foods...
...dough cooked in oil, they call it Indian fry bread.
And grandma said she wants a whole floor to herself,...
...smelling like fry bread.